yesterday we heard from the man who was
held at gunpoint with kim kardashian
when she was robbed in Paris tonight
he gives us an even clearer picture of
why this assault could haunt him for the
rest of her life
did Kim ask you if you both were going
to die he asked me when I I tried to
calm her and she told me we gonna die I
thought her and that why I don't know I
don't know 25 days after Kim Kardashian
was robbed at gunpoint in Paris the
reality star is slowly stepping back
into the spotlight Kim also reportedly
plans to take north and st.
trick-or-treating on Monday although
she'll likely stay safely within her
gated community a source close to Kim
tells us quote Kim is definitely ready
to start getting back to her normal life
little by little she's taking it
day-by-day
and isn't pushing it all that is
frightening new details are emerging
about the ordeal from the only other
witness Abdul Rahman was working
security at the hotel that night he was
also tied up and had a gun held to his
head how is Kim reacting to all this she
all screaming and she was very terrified
I know very very terrified and she
stopped her to tell them to don't hurt
her don't kill her don't kidding me
don't hurt me
I have babies I am mom I think she gives
the age on her babies you know one of
the robbers had taken Kim's phone when
the phone rang I saw Pascal the name of
the bodyguard and I thought the guy you
know who is calling now he's her
bodyguard and if she didn't answer him
now he will come with police at that
point the robbers quickly left taking
with them 5.6 million dollars worth of
Kim's jewellery I think an experience
like these it will change for life it
will change her for sure